fait que il roule dans une voiture qui
est immatriculé en polne il n'a pas de
permis il a 17 ans elle n'est pas assuré
non mais ça fait jours
qu' pardon tu peux arrêter quelqu'un
sans
exéé tu crois que vraiment ce policier
le matin disant Z je vais tuer là c'est
bien c'est un super métier il font des
métiers c'est des
humains dis la céérité doit être la même
pour un policier ou pour un délinquant
moi je crois pas du tout non pardon mais
la société pe pas punir de la même façon
un policier quelqu'un qui est là pour te
protéger pour faire en sorte que cette
personne là qui a une arme dans la main
éventuellement ne blesse pas quelqu'un
d'autre après je ve dire c'est de ça
donag la
questionuseb le débat est quand même
assz incroyable parce que excusez-moi
les policiers sont là pour faire
appliquer la loi aucune personne au
monde lorsqu'elle obéit
au policiers quand les policiers
demandent de vous arrêter ne risqueent
quoi que ce soit à partir du moment à
partir du moment où vous décider d'en
freindre la loi en nérant pas à des gens
qui sont dépositaires de l'autorité
publique c'est ça l'État de droit on se
gargarise de l'État de droit uniquement
bizarrement quand il s'agit de pas
expulser des gens en dehors des
frontières mais l'état de droit il
commence là et si vous si vous obtemprez
pas ben vous mettez le doigt dans un
engrenage qui peut vous conduire à des
drames mais c'est la faute de qui à la
fin à la faute de celui qui n'a
pastempéré n'a pas été respecté pour ce
policier qui a demandé donc des des du
parloir systématiquement et le parloir
lui a été refusé depuis juin voilà donc
c'est quand même incroyable justement
pour vous donc sa place n'était pas en
prison vous avez des nouvelles de sa
famille je suis en contact avec sa
famille j'ai eu son épouse tout à
l'heure il vous a dit quoi bah qui m'a
dit qu'elle était soulagée c'est ça de
voir son son mari libérer ils ont dû
déménager d'ailleurs c'est une famille
qui a été c'est une famille qui qui est
allé qui qui est entrée dans la
tourmente dès le 27 juin puisque leur
adresse a été dénoncée sur les réseaux
sociaux ils ont été obligés de déménager
dans un contexte où où le traitement
c'est le salaire du policier et je parle
sous le contrôle de monsieur bellad a
été interrompu donc ils ont eu des frais
de déménagement le l'adresse de leur
hôtel a été à nouveau dénoncée ils ont
été obligés de déménager dans un autre
hôtel ils ont un enfant en basâge et
bizarrement la société a trouvé ça
incroyable en tout cas une partie de de
des médias et des politiques a trouvé ça
incroyable qu'on fasse preuve de
compassion vis-à-vis de la famille de ce
policier vous avez CR obligé d'avoir de
la compassion pour la famille d'un petit
voyou ça çaavait pas de problème mais
par contre pour la famille d'un policier
alors ça il fallait pas il fallait pas
en avoir s vous plaît vous avez cré une
cagnotte Jean méia oui pour le policier
pourquoi vous êtes mêlé de cette affaire
vous parce que j'ai trouvé ça incroyable
que effectivement on crée enfin on met
la famille d'un policier dans une
situation pareille j'ai estimé que
l'État en tout cas l'administration qui
au nom de laquelle il il est intervenu
dans la rue ne le ne le protégeit pas
assez ne protégeit pas assz sa famille
et je suis comme des millions de
Français j'éta scandalisé par le
traitement de ce policier combien sur la
cagnotte 1632000 € ah ou quand même pour
87000 donateurs alors qui qui qui a
touché l'argent bah sa femme ça y est
c'est bon oui ah ouais maintenant
passé dire qu'
tu je va apporter une petite
précision une petite précision faut
savoir qu'ussi l'amical des motards du
92 a ouvert une quête qui elle n'a enfin
n'a que nous on l'a fait pour la famille
parce que malheureusement on a plusieurs
cas où les les femmes et les enfants se
retrouvent seuls on a récolté enfin
l'amical des motards du des hautes scèes
a récolté 85000 € qui eux sont la la
famille peut les utiliser par d'accord
mais l'autre le million il est sous
sesqua non il il est pas enfin il est
pas sous sesqua c'est queà dire que
comme il y a une procédure la famille
préfère pour l'instant ne pas y toucher
mais ils l'ont ils l'ont touché ilsont
touché euh vous êtes convoqué par la
police pourquoi alors euh quand j'ai
ouvert cette cagnotte évidemment la
gauche et l'extrême gauche les
parlementaires et cetera vous avez des
débats homériques à l'Assemblée
nationale se sont offusqués de cette
cagnotte et donc on saisit euh d'abord
le procureur et la famille de Naël a
porté plainte contre moi tenez-vous bien
pour escroquerie en bande organisée donc
moi évidemment moi le motif je suis
tombé des NU je me dis le parquet je pas
touché 1 € au vousout de la cagnotte bah
moi en fait quand on ouvre une cagnotte
ceux qui ouvrent des cagnottes le savent
on est obligé de donner la pièce
d'identité du bénéficiaire et le relevé
d'identité bancaire du bénéficiaire qui
en l'occurrence c'était pas moi donc
l'argent n'a pas transité par moi ni par
aucun tiers l'argent de la cagnote a été
versé directement sur le compte du
bénéficiaire c'est-à-dire l'épouse du
policier ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que qu'elle n'a pas
été ma surprise que le parquet sur des
motifs aussi fallacieux a décidé en 24
heures d'ouvrir une enquête donc moi je
me suis dit bon bah si c'est ça je vais
porter plainte moi contre la cagnotte
ouverte pour la pour la famille de naë
pour les mêmes motifs dans une forme de
smétrie vous risquez quoi jusqu'à
aujourd'hui le parquet ne m'a toujours
pas répondu donc après quand on veut me
vendre l'idée d'une justice indépendante
et impartiale excusez-moi j'en ai eu ma
coupe risquz quoi bah pour l'instant
rien parce que je convoqué en en
auditeur en audition libre donc ah
d'accord donc ça va voilà donc si vous
voulez parce que le problème il est quoi
on escroqué en bande organisé j'ai
escroqué qui quel bénéfici j'en ai tiré
personnellement moi financier rien si
j'ai escroqué les 87000 donateurs de la
cagnote c'est à eux de porter plainte
pour escer bizarrement personne l'a fait
donc à moins qu'il considère que les
87000 personnes c'est la bande organisée
au quel cas les donateurs vont porter
plainte pour diffamation Jean mess ce
qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a pris des
informations confidentielles du
traitement des antécédents fa c'est pas
prouvé ça arrêté défamé c'est faux c'est
ce pour quoi vous allez être entendu on
est d'accord qu' vous fait je peux même
pas
placer ce qu'on ce qu'on vous reproche
d'avoir fait ce que la famille de Nel
vous reproche d'avoir fait c'est d'avoir
pris des informations avoir divulgué ces
informations confidentielles Cyril pour
criminaliser Naël et donc les donateurs
ont donné en croyant que Naël était un
criminel
multirécidivisteà pourquoi ils ont pas
porté plainte ils ont donné pour une
raisonon PL il en a aucun qui a porté
plainte non mais c'est la famille et
l'avocat de la famille donc a déposé une
plainte qui a été jugée recevable et il
y a une enquête autour de ça
voilà mais mais c'est
c'est cousu de fil blanc pas du tout
j'ai pris les informations qui étaient
disponibles à l'instanté d'ailleurs je
ne suis pas convoqué pour ces motif
vousê convoqué pour quoi alors je suis
convoqué uniquement sur le chef
d'accusation descr band organisé parce
que Le Rest ne tient pas la route c'est
ça lesc B organisé je viens de vous la
définir c'est incroyable ça vous faites
le boss sur une affaire et maintenant
vous présentez comme la victime
impossible vous dites que j'ai trompé
les donateurs est-ce que c'est la
justice d'accord la justice est-ce que
un seul donateur aortter plainte je je
vous parle de la justice vous parle pas
des donateurs c'est pas ça quel est
l'intérêt de la famille à agir pour le
compte de donateurs est-ce que les
donateurs ont donné procuration à la
famille de Naël pour porter plainte
contre moi pour
escroquerie et
pourquoi et deuxème question la famille
si si ouvrir une cagnot si ouvrir une
cagnotte si ouvrir une cagnotte vous
vaut d'être accusé d'escroquer en bande
organisé moi j'ai porté plainte contre
la famille de Naël pour escroquerer en
bande organisée pourquoi le parquet ne
m'a toujours pas répondu pl elle est
bidon alors que Laure elle est
recevableelle est pas recevable elle est
recevable politiquement voilà la vérité
c'est pour calmer les zones de non
France après les émeutes voilà c'est
tout c'est ça la vérité vous ser entendu
lundi je serai entendu lundi ouais faut
VI raconter si vous voulez bien pour moi
c'est une convocation politique parce
que et même l'acceptation de la plainte
par le parquet à l'époque on était
encore dans les émeutes le parquet
probablement sous l'influence sous
l'influence de journaliste gaucho
progressiste dont vous êtes d'accord il
a décidé effectivement d'envoyer
d'envoyer un signal aux zones de non
France pour les calmer parce que c'est
politique c'est tout ça n rien d'autre
vous nous direz lundi d'accord je vous
dirai lundiès merci tout de suite c'est
mon